un fromage ou un yaourt bio logique tout
droit venus d'île de france c'est
l'objectif que s'est donné la bergerie
nationale à rambouillet cela fait déjà
huit mois que le lait est certifiée
biologique
la structure est inauguré jeudi 1er
décembre son nouvel atelier de
transformation
la production de lait est ancienne ce
qui a changé ces dernières années c'est
la conduite du troupeau puisque nous
respectons maintenant les principes de
l'agro écologie et nous sommes
labellisés agriculture biologique donc
dans ce cadre là on a réfléchi aussi à
la commercialisation de nos produits
puisque c'est bien de produire un lait
de qualité biologique mais il faut aussi
avoir les circuits qui permettent de
commercialiser à proximité est
transformé à proximité entre l'ue et ces
circuits sont représentés par deux
partenaires la ferme de 6 j ai la
société hôte nta dans leur nouveau local
il développe sur place toute une gamme
de produits laitiers
destiné aux particuliers mais aussi aux
cantines scolaires
la production de rambouillet aller
montera les yvelines et le val d'oise où
les collectivités locales c'est à dire
les collèges les lycées les écoles
primaires ça va représenter à terme
un quart de notre chiffre d'affaires
donc de notre nouveau chiffre d'affaires
et ça va représenter à peu près une
production de 30 mille yaourt
supplémentaires par semaine n'est pas
simplement un producteur d'une matière
première on est on est vraiment là pour
faire de l'alimentation et donc on a on
a un vrai échange entre les
transformateurs et nous les producteurs
pour sans cesse adapter nos pratiques et
notre système de production en fonction
des rendu qu'on a sur la partie
transformation avec le passage au
biologique la bergerie nationale a pu
valoriser sa production vendue
auparavant 250 euros les mille litres
elle atteint maintenant 570 euros une
manière de se développer dans une
filière en danger en 15 ans la moitié
des exploitations agricoles a disparu